ضعنا في صوره ما يجري في هذه المدينه
المكتظه بالسكان لدرجه كبيره والتي لطالما
تحدثت عن الاعداد الكبيره من النازحين
فيها
تفضل نعم ليلى هي اوضاع صعبه وكارثه
للغايه مع استمرار امد الحرب الاسرائيليه
على القطاع وايضا اوضاع تزيد صعوبه مع قله
المساعدات التي تاتي الى القطاع عبر معبر
رفح او كرم ابو سالم اليوم سجل فقط دخول
خمس شاحنات فقط عبر معبر رفح البري دون ان
تدخل اي مساعدات طبيه او تموينيه سواء
للاونروا او منظمات دوليه اخرى او حتى
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني على الصعيد
الميداني تزداد الامور صعوبه في مختلف
مناطق قطاع غزه تحديدا خلال الساعتين
الاخيرتين شنت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه سلسله من الاحزمه الناريه
والغارات الجويه استهدفت منازل وشقق سكنيه
تحديدا في في مدينتي في مدينه غزه وايضا
في مخيم النصيرات كان اعنف هذه الغارات هو
في مخيم النصيرات هو قصف اسرائيلي استهدف
منزل
لعائله المطوي في منطقه السواره غرب مخيم
النصيرات ادت هذه الغاره هذا المنزل طبعا
مكون من عده طوابق ويؤوي اكثر من 80 نازحا
ادت هذه الغاره حتى هذه اللحظه الى ارتقاء
23 شهيدا بالاضافه الى عشرات الجرحى وفرق
الدفاع المدني لازالت تعمل بين انقاض هذا
المنزل لانتشال جثامين شهداء وانقاذ حياه
جرحى بالاضافه الى قصف اخر استهدف شقه
سكنيه شرق مخيم ذات شرق مخيم النصيرات
لعائله النابلسيه ادى الى ارتقاء اربعه من
الشهداء وايضا غاره جويه اخرى على مخيم
الشاطئ استهدفت منزلا لعائله شحاده ادى
الى ارتقاء اكثر من 10 شهداء بالاضافه الى
عشرات الجرحى وشقه سكنيه اخرى في حي
الرمال ادت الى ارتقاء ثلاثه من الشهداء
هذه الغارات جميعها التي ذكرتها هي خلال
ساعتين فقط فقط وادت الى ارتقاء اكثر من
40 جريح اكثر من 40 شهيدا الى جانب مئات
الجرحى الذين وصلوا الى مستشفى الشفاء
وايضا الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح ومستشفى العوده في النصيرات
بالتزامن مع ذلك اوضاع كارثيه تعيش
المنطقه الجنوبيه تحديدا في مدينه خان
يونس اضطر الناس داخل مجمع ناصر الطبي الى
دفن جثامين 35 شهيدا في مقبره جماعيه الى
جانب ايضا النقص الحاد في المواد
التموينيه وايضا الطبيه وحصار مدرسه هارون
الرشيد في حي الامل ومدرسه ايضا اي مدرسه
الحي الياباني في غرب مدينه خان يونس
بوجود عدد من الاصابات داخل هذه المدرسه
على وجه التحديد ومناشدات للصليب الاحمر
بضروره فتح ممر انساني لاجلاء الاصابات
الخطيره داخل هذه المدارس التي تتبع ل
الامم المتحده وتؤوي الاف النازحين بال
وايضا هنا في المنطقه الج قصف مدفعي
اسرائيلي شرق مدينتي رفع على وجه التحديد
في محيط موقع صوفا وايضا في محيط موقع كرم
ابو سالم الى الجنوب الشرقي من مدينه رفح
شكرا جزيلا لك مؤمن الشرافي من رفح على
هذه
التفاصيل